AMY UNRUH: Hi, my name
is Amy Unruh.
KIM CAMERON: And my name
is Kim Cameron.
And I am addicted to robots.
So when I first heard about the
idea of the internet of
things, that we can have all
sorts of interconnected
machines that talk and do things
for humans, I thought,
this is totally awesome.
Finally I can have a robot
butler that brings me things.
Maybe it wipes off my forehead,
I don't know why.
But I'm just going to say the
elephant in the room here.
I know someone else
is thinking this.
Think about a bunch of
interconnected machines.
They're doing stuff for us.
They're intelligent.
There is one additional thing
that comes to mind.
Nobody wants this.
No one wants robot overlords.
Why are we even talking
about robots?
You're here to hear about data
sensing lab project that we
did at Moscone.
We wanted to build an internet
of things app that helped us
see more about what's going
on than what you
normally could see.
We didn't want to create
a robot army.
We wanted to create an army of
sensor motes that we could put
up around the conference and get
all sorts of data in, show
it to you in really cool ways.
And, again, to show us things
that we couldn't normally see.
Slides are malfunctioning
like a robot.
So we wanted our app to do
cool stuff like this.
This is a chart of
noise yesterday.
As you can see during the party,
Billy Idol, huge noise.
And our app is going to do a lot
of other stuff than this.
But before we get into that,
let's talk about how the
project got started.
So back in February our
colleague, Michael Manoochehri
was at Strata.
And he was intrigued by a
project by the O'Reilly data
sensing lab team.
The setup was fairly similar
to what we're doing here.
There were about 50 motes.
They were set up across
the conference.
They gathered a bunch of
environmental data.
And based on that we were shown
visualizations about
what was going on.
And Michael thought,
this is great.
Why not bigger?
So we took 500 Arduino boards
for our project.
And to each of these boards we
added a custom sensor shield
which was added by Kipp Bradford
or kippkitts, and
Alasdair Allen of Babilim
Light Industries.
Yes.
And each of these shields has
a bunch of sensors on it.
Noise, light, humidity,
some other built ins.
As well as three optional
sensors for air quality.
Also RF, which we have
tuned to GSM.
As well as motions.
So you might have seen
these mats around.
We even had one in the car.
And that was registering when
people were stepping on them
and stepping off.
And the shield and the Arduino
boards put together make up a
mote, which is essentially a
node in a sensory network.
I'm sure you've seen
them around.
They have little blinky lights,
cute signs, all that.
We put them up all over Moscone
on all of the floors,
including in some interesting
spaces such as I
mentioned in the car.
There were a few in that blimp
that was circling around the
second floor.
We wanted to get readings
all over the place.
In fact, I believe there was
a mote in that really noisy
architect game last night.
The next problem was how
would these motes
talk to each other?
So some of you might
be thinking, OK
set up a Wi-Fi network.
And the issue with that is we
would have to set up wireless
routers everywhere for the range
to work for the motes.
Instead we put up
a mesh network.
So the idea behind the mesh
network is, let's say that
there's a node that's close
to its gateway.
It needs to get its
information there.
That's fine.
It sends the information.
The gateway is right next by.
But what about motes
that are farther
away, at farther range?
They can just talk to the nearby
mote which then hops
the message along through
the motes until
it gets to the gateway.
This allows for a much
greater range.
So we have an XP radio on
each of the shields.
And it's communicating over a
ZigBee protocol which some of
you might be familiar with.
This network was set up by our
partners Digi International.
They also worked on the
Strata project.
And they have a product called
Device Cloud by Etherios.
So what's happening is each
sensor mote is sending its
readings every 20 seconds to the
gateways which are going
to device cloud by Etherios.
They even do just a little bit
like add a time stamp then
they send it to us.
So on our end we needed to
create a software solution to
manage this.
This is a challenging problem.
How do you even get
started with this?
We knew it had to be scalable.
We didn't want to focus much on
the infrastructure which is
why we wanted to try out
the cloud platform.
And luckily, the woman who coded
most of this project is
standing next to
me, Amy Unruh.
So Amy, how do we get started
with this challenge?
AMY UNRUH: Well Kim.
KIM CAMERON: Oh I apologize.
I missed some slides.
So--
AMY UNRUH: The suspense.
KIM CAMERON: The suspense.
I apologize.
So I just wanted to show you
a few visualizations
before we moved on.
And, ooh I don't know what's
happening there.
Now I've lost--
all right.
I'm just going to
look up here.
Or maybe I can--
here we go.
So this is a live visual of
temperature readings on the
second floor.
So as you can see, these
two rooms are
apparently very popular.
As well as, this is like
the cloud sandbox area.
All the other sandbox areas.
And I'm not sure what's over
here, but it's also very high
temperature.
I apologize for my ineptness
at getting out of this.
As well, this is an interesting
correlation that
was done by our friends
at Tableau.
They have a really
cool connector
that hooks up to BigQuery.
And it shows really neat
visualizations.
So this is a chart of air
quality versus steps on that
motion pad.
So as you can see with the green
above and below, the
number of steps to indicate
drop in air quality, which
means there's a bunch of us
smelly nerds walking around.
And that's ruining
the air quality.
So now we'll get to Amy Unruh.
I apologize for the delay.
To talk about the software
solution.
AMY UNRUH: So the first thing
that we needed to think about
was how to get this barrage
of data into the system.
So the sensors are feeding us
data at a really high rate.
We need to suck into
our system.
We don't want our app
to fall over.
We don't want it to lose data.
And we need to get it to some
place where it's persistent.
Where it's safe.
This whole framework that we're
building to ingest the
data we've been calling
the pipeline.
And as Kim said, we use the
cloud platform for this.
And, in fact, we use multiple
pieces of the cloud platform.
Did any of you get a chance to
see the great all of the ships
of the world talk
earlier today?
Yeah, that was fantastic.
And they also had what I would
consider a platform.
Ours this is a little
different.
They're serving slightly
different needs.
But this is, they're somewhat
similar patterns.
Foundations for sucking a lot
of data into a system really
quickly so you can start to do
interesting things with it.
So let's look at how
we did this.
The first step, just
ingesting the data,
bringing it safely in.
We're using App Engine
for this.
App Engine is part of
the cloud platform.
It's designed for simplicity and
for letting you deploy a
web apps at Google scale.
And we are using, in particular,
three features of
App Engine to do this.
First of all, it scalability.
App Engine auto scales
for you.
So as more and more sensor motes
come online our app is
going to scale up
to handle that.
We don't need to pay attention
to that or do anything.
And we don't need to do
any provisioning.
And, in fact, we watched
this happen over
the past day or two.
It worked really well.
The second thing that we're
doing is, as we ingest the
data we're processing in the
background using task queues,
App Engine task queues.
This might be one of my favorite
App Engine features.
Essentially task queues
let you run processes
asynchronously to the request
response cycle of the app.
And so as data comes flooding in
we're bundling it off to an
army of task queue tasks to
actually do the processing.
And that lets our app stay
really responsive and really
high throughput.
And then, finally, we're using
the App Enginge Cloud
Datastore to store this data as
it comes into the system.
The cloud data store is managed
really robust, highly
scalable, distributed
new SQL Datastore.
It's perfect for this.
We can throw a large amount of
data at it really quickly.
It doesn't even blink.
And it can get really large and
we can still get data out
very quickly.
So we're using the data
store for our
initial data ingestion.
So what happens next, Kim?
KIM CAMERON: So I'm glad
you asked, Amy.
We next need to get our
data into BigQuery.
AMY UNRUH: So actually we just
got our data into the
Datastore, so why do
we need to do that?
KIM CAMERON: I am
glad you asked.
So BigQuery lets you query
huge, huge data sets in a
matter of seconds.
And it also supports something
that we're going to be using
our visualizations.
And that's aggregate queries.
BigQuery is also good at
things like regular
expressions and other
complex queries.
So we know we want to get the
data into BigQuery so we can
use it for these
visualizations.
So to do this we have two
things to consider.
First, we need to do some stuff
with our data before we
move it in.
Specifically we transform the
data to put it into a schema
that BigQuery expects.
Second, we're going to
join some data in
with our sensor data.
So we have mote data
that we're also
storing in data store.
It has information about the
motes like its location, its
name, other information.
So we join all that together
in App Engine first.
And now we have the data that we
want to move into BigQuery.
So where are we going
to put it?
We're going to move it
into cloud storage.
This is the recommended way that
we suggest you move your
data into BigQuery.
You could have also sent
a post request and
attached the data.
The advantage of staging it on
Google Cloud Storage first is
that for one it's quick.
For two, you have a copy
of your data there now.
Let's say you wanted to share
the data set, you have it on
cloud storage ready to go.
Ready to link people to.
So we need to move our data to
cloud storage, but there's
something else that we need to
consider, and that's how
frequently do we move the
data to BigQuery?
Because there's quotas on the
amount of loads you can do per
day, we don't want to just shove
data at it every single
time we get a reading.
So we want to be careful and
batch up the data and move it
when it's appropriate.
So how we're accomplishing this
is we're using another
kind of App Engine task queue.
Tasks on the task queue.
Which run not as frequently.
They check the data store.
They see, is there enough
unprocessed data here to
warrant doing a load, and if so
it's going to move the data
into cloud storage.
All right, so now the data is in
cloud storage ready to go.
Someone has to push the button
to actually move the data from
cloud storage into BigQuery.
Amy, who is that going to be?
It's not me.
AMY UNRUH: That's going to be
a Compute Engine instance.
And as you guys probably know,
Compute Engine lets you run
really flexible, fast, virtual
machines in the cloud.
So we're going to use Compute
Engine to pull this data in.
And it's going to instruct
BigQuery to do these low jobs.
Tell BigQuery to get the
data from cloud storage
and to load it in.
KIM CAMERON: So now
I'm confused, Amy.
Because since our data is in App
Engine, why don't we just
have App Engine move the
data into BigQuery?
AMY UNRUH: So that's
a good question.
In fact, you could do
this very easily in
App Engine, as well.
There's an API that
accomplishes this.
It's really easy to use.
And the reason that we're
using Compute Engine is
because we're already using it
for other parts of our system.
We already have instances
launched.
And this is a really long
running, kind of boring, batch
script that's running.
So it's really appropriate
just to run it on Compute
Engine and forget about it.
KIM CAMERON: OK, so
that's great.
So how does compute know when
it should move the data from
cloud storage to BigQuery?
AMY UNRUH: So this is actually
really interesting design
pattern that we're using here.
And if you saw the all the ships
of the world talk you
might have caught this being
used with them as well.
We're using pool queues.
App engine pull queues.
So pull queues have
a REST API.
And they essentially let you
place messages, one process
can place a bunch of messages
on this pool queue.
And other processes can pull
off the messages and do
something with that
information.
So as App Engine batches all
of its data into cloud
storage, it's creating messages
on this pool cue that
give information about the
files that it's created.
And then Compute Engine, this
long running script, is going
pool many hundreds of those
messages off in batch.
So we're magnifying our
batch processing here.
And really quickly construct a
load job that goes off and
tells BigQuery to load
all these files.
So it's really efficient.
OK, so what we've described
here is this pipeline, the
foundation of our system.
It's how where ingesting lots of
data at a high rate and how
we're storing putting it where
we want it to be in two
different persistent stores.
And this was actually pretty
straightforward to build.
It certainly wasn't trivial,
but it was pretty
straightforward.
And we built it, just a few of
us developers in a short
period of time.
And this is actually
pretty cool.
Because this can be a hard
problem, especially at scale.
And the reason it was so
straightforward is because all
of the pieces of the cloud
platform that we were using
are so robust and scalable in
their own right and talk so
easily to each other.
So that it was a really
cool result.
So now we have this foundation,
this pipeline.
And we can start to do all sorts
of really fun things
with the data that
we're collecting.
KIM CAMERON: So now we can get
to those cool visualizations
we are looking at
earlier today.
And we have a few to show you.
So first off, we're doing
visualizations based on both
of our data stores.
We're using both data store
and we're using BigQuery.
And, again, it depends
on what type of
visualizations we want to do.
So in this example, this is
going to be another live demo.
And this one is, it's a little
bit hard to see there.
But these are the pressure
mats that are
on the first floor.
So if you look in this area
here, these are the
escalators.
AMY UNRUH: They're
counting steps.
KIM CAMERON: And you can also
see there's a lot of traffic
here by both sets of doors.
And I don't know what this
is, but it's curious.
So this one is getting data
from data storage.
Just getting the last x values
very quick to do there.
We don't need to
use any sort of
complicated aggregate queries.
And we have a lot of
things like this.
You can look at recent
light readings, noise
readings stuff like that.
So now here's the
visualization that uses BigQuery.
This is the 40 noisiest
minutes at
Google I/O thus far.
This is from yesterday, and so
you'll notice there's a spike.
It's around the same
time as the party.
So this is pretty similar to
the other visualizations,
really noisy going on there.
And this one is using
an aggregate query.
So this is the BigQuery
query we're
running to get this result.
As you can see, we're using the
average function which is
an aggregate.
And it's just checking the most
recent 40 loudest rooms
based on average.
So let's run a query live.
And you can see the results.
So, as a note, we have made the
BigQuery data set public.
Any of you can have access
to that now.
We have a resources slide at the
end that has a link to the
data sensing lab.
You can also check out the
kiosks for the link.
And it gives you instructions
on where to get the data set
and how to find it.
AMY UNRUH: Which is
incidentally still
growing as we speak.
KIM CAMERON: Yes.
So, we are going to do--
I apologize.
It's not showing up on
my laptop, so I am
doing it this way.
AMY UNRUH: Query history
as well.
KIM CAMERON: Sorry?
AMY UNRUH: Query history.
Either way.
So view the query history.
KIM CAMERON: It's hard
to see on here.
OK.
It's the pregnant
pause moment.
There we go!
Hooray!
AMY UNRUH: I thought we
were going to have
to sing show tunes.
KIM CAMERON: All right.
So this is the results
of BigQuery.
You can see the rooms and other
information about it.
And just for fun let's also look
at one for temperature.
If I can find it.
Here we go.
So Android East, hottest room.
Room 12, not sure
what that is.
Keynote West.
Pixel, I guess that's when
you were all picking
up your free pixels.
So interesting information.
And so for these we really
needed to use BigQuery due to
the aggregates.
Now, in addition to these
visualizations, we wanted to
be able to do things like
maybe find correlations
between data or at
least facilitate
that for the future.
This is a really hard problem.
And we had to figure out
how to set this up.
So Amy, how did we get
started with this?
AMY UNRUH: So one thing
that we're doing--
So, again, basically want to
start surfacing interesting
patterns and mining all this
data and in addition to the
visualizations that
we're doing.
So one thing we're doing is
we're actually monitoring for
particular things that we know
we want to look for.
And one simple example of this
is we want to watch for motes
as they go on and offline.
So we expected there would be
a lot of reasons that they
would do this.
People unplugging them to
use their cell phones.
Kicking them.
Those motes are pretty cute.
And we thought those motes, some
of them might just take a
bit of a walk.
So we're running background
tasks to detect when they go
on and offline.
And we're mapping that.
And see if I can bring
up a live version.
Sort of disturbingly,
there's, whoops.
Yeah.
Why don't you do it
while I talk?
KIM CAMERON: I don't
know the link
AMY UNRUH: Just click
on missing.
Sort of disturbingly, there's a
lot more missing motes today
than there were yesterday,
for some reason.
It's all right.
We'll just look at
the screen shot.
This should be showing up on
your kiosks as well scattered
around Moscone.
There were a lot more when I
checked an hour or so ago than
there were yesterday.
So there's all sorts of
monitoring tasks that we want
to do like this.
We've set up, again with the
task queues, the App Engine
task queues, we've set up
a framework to do this.
Where we can specify, define the
kinds of things we want to
monitor and how frequently
we want to look for them.
And we just set them loose.
Again, running in
the background.
And App Engine will scale
these up for us.
So we can look for a whole lot
of things really scalable as
this flood of data comes in.
So that's one thing
we're doing.
But more broadly, we need to
start mining this data.
Looking for interesting
patterns.
And as any data scientist in
the audience will know,
there's just a whole arsenal
out there of libraries and
packages that help you do
this kind of thing.
For example, [INAUDIBLE],
all sorts of things.
So we've got all this data, now
we can start feeding it to
some of these great
analysis packages.
KIM CAMERON: And I assume we're
going to be doing this
on App Engine.
AMY UNRUH: Well, I'm sorry
to break it to you, Kim.
Many of these packages actually
don't run on App Engine.
The reason relates to how App
Engine packages or sandboxes
some of its services.
However, all of these
packages run really
well on Compute Engine.
And so that's where we're
going to do it.
And there is something that was
just announced yesterday
that many of you might
have caught.
That just really facilitates
this and is
really pretty exciting.
And that is the announcement
of the
Google Cloud data store.
This is essentially an API that
processes outside App
Engine can use to access
App Engines data store.
And so this means that as
we're running all this
analysis on Compute Engine or on
other processes we can tap
directly into App Engine
app data stores.
And grab the data directly.
We don't have to do any
shuttling around.
We can post the results back
into App Engine's data store.
And, in fact, we don't
necessarily even really need
to use App Engine at all.
Although, of course, we're
using it for this system.
So this is really cool.
This makes this kind of analysis
really easy to do.
And just as a quick example,
let me show you a little
script I wrote to grab,
this is Python.
And I don't expect you to look
at it in gory detail.
But what this script
does is it's
running in Compute Engine.
It's grabbing some of our sensor
data that we've been
storing, directly from
our apps data store.
It's doing some transformations
on it.
It's going to create
some CSV files.
So if you look at this code, I
won't spend too much time on
it, but anyone who's done a
little bit of App Engine
programming will recognize
the structure of it.
It's the same structure
in terms of
talking to the data store.
We're formulating a query.
We're adding some filters.
We're specifying the order that
we want the results back.
And then we're submitting
the query.
It's really fast.
It works really well.
And so then we, in this
particular case, with this
script, we generate
a CSV file.
And this is just a snippet of
it just to show you the
structure in this
particular case.
And once we have something like
this, for example, we can
run analysis on it using R.
So this is just one little
example to give you
the flavor of it.
In this case, we're looking
for correlations between
streams of different sensors
on the same mote.
So one particular mote.
And we're saying, are we finding
correlations between
sensor stream A and
sensor stream B.
And so, for example, in this
case this mote had both
humidity and temperature
sensors.
And we're finding that there's a
strong negative correlation,
apparently.
I saw this on more than one
mote, between humidity and
temperature.
So this kind of thing.
So to reiterate, this
is really exciting.
The fact that we can run these
analysis jobs directly from
Compute Engine tapping into the
Google Cloud data storage.
This really opened up a whole
new world of analysis.
And we have lots more that we're
going to do with this.
KIM CAMERON: So Amy, it sounds
like our apps going really
well so far.
How about performance?
We had to have done some
stuff to make the app
perform much better.
What did we do?
AMY UNRUH: Actually our
app was perfect.
We didn't have to do
any performance.
[LAUGHTER]
AMY UNRUH: You guys know that
can't possibly be the case.
Yeah, so, in fact, we had to
do a lot of performance
optimizations.
So one thing that I won't really
go into here, but was
really crucial for
it, was caching.
So we put in a really strong
caching layer.
And for that we used App
Engine's Memcache service and
it worked great.
So that's why our app is running
as smoothly as it is.
But one thing I wanted to
particularly call out is as
being kind of an interesting way
of improving performance,
is something new.
It's an App Engine feature
called App Engine Servers.
And it's in limited preview.
Which means that you have
to sign up to use it.
So if you're interested in the
resource slide at the end,
we've put a sign up link.
So with App Engine servers you
define logical instance
configurations, essentially
server groups, multiple server
groups for your App
Engine app.
And then you can define how
your incoming requests are
routed to one particular server
group or another.
So you're essentially
partitioning your app.
Different classes of request can
get handled by different
server groups.
An App Engine is going to
consider the scheduling and
scaling of each server
group separately.
So if you, as many apps do, have
incoming requests with
lots of variability.
Some really high latency
requests,
some low latency requests.
Maybe a lot of number
crunching.
If you can partition the
handling of hose requests, App
Engine can manage the app
really efficiently.
And so in our particular case,
we had three different classes
of activities that we're
doing in our app.
So one is the data ingestion
which needs to be really rapid
and very quick.
Then we're doing a lot of data
processing of various types,
all sort of slow, slower
compared to the data ingestion.
And then we're handling
the visualization.
All of the client requests
to see the neat
stuff that we're building.
And so we really saw
improvements in our app by
dividing these different
activities in two different
server groups.
KIM CAMERON: So, like with any
software development process,
we did run some challenges
along the way.
And I'm going to tell you just
about a few of them right now.
So, first of all, entering
the mote data.
We needed the mote data entered
so we could join it
with our sensor data.
And then we can move it into
BigQuery, do all the stuff
we've talked about already.
So that was a manual process.
And one challenge is we had to
build an admin panel to help
the hardware guys move all the
mote data in manually.
And, of course, humans are not
robots so they make mistakes.
And so occasionally we had to
deal with issues like there
would be a mislabeled mote.
And so then we'd suddenly get
a reading from some strange
mote we didn't recognize.
And we had to have a way to
really look for those issues
and fix them.
I'd say the biggest challenge
we had was prioritization.
We started this app only about
a month ago and with very
limited developer resources.
So we had to choose carefully
the things we wanted to do to
build this foundation.
We had to focus on the
pipeline and the
visualizations, primarily.
And really the takeaway from
this is we've just gotten
started on this.
We hope that you'll
follow the blog.
We want to put installations
of this up in the future.
And we also plan on
open-sourcing this code at
some point after I/O so you
guys can look at it
and work on it too.
As well as having access to
the data set and BigQuery.
So I guess what I would end with
is, use these patterns.
Use these practices.
Go out and build your own
internet of things apps that
help change the world
and how you see it.
Just please, for all of
our sakes, do not
build a robot army.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
KIM CAMERON: So, oops, so we
have time for about 10 minutes
of questions.
And we have mics in both of
the aisles for anyone who
would like to come up and ask.
I apologize I'm not able
to make the slides big.
Which side?
How about you?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
I noticed that there were
somewhere around 500 motes out
on the floor.
How does this problem change
if you increase that number
to, for example, let's
say, 5,000 or
let's say 500,000 motes.
Or even, let's say 50 million.
Maybe 50 million is a
little bit too much.
But a very, very large amount,
for example, in a cable
network or something where
there's maybe not with motes,
but with different devices.
AMY UNRUH: So what we're seeing,
what we're seeing
right now is that App Engine is
not even really breaking a
sweat drawing in this data.
And so we have every reason to
believe that will scale up
very gracefully to much
larger installations.
Yeah.
I couldn't speak to millions
and millions of motes, but
certainly we could have an order
of magnitude more motes
and I wouldn't expect
any problem at all.
AUDIENCE: With the same--
AMY UNRUH: With the same
configuration.
AUDIENCE: I actually have a
hardware question for you.
And I've been looking forward
to this ever since I saw the
mote sitting around
everywhere.
No I'm not one of the ones that
took one, although I was
really tempted, I'll
have to admit.
But I'm actually working on a
project doing some sensing of
growing conditions in the
tropical regions.
And so when I saw XP motes and
you have all the right sensors
on there and everything.
So you said those are
custom shields?
Are they going to be available
somewhere?
KIM CAMERON: So the fellows
that made the shields,
actually they're in
the audience here.
So there around for questions
afterwards as well.
There's Alasdair right there.
I don't know if Kipp's here.
And they are playing an
open sourcing the
board at some point.
So you can get more information
about that at
their website which is
datasensinglab.com.
Of you can feel free to chat
with Alasdair afterwards.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Well I see that you started
with cloud storage then to
BigQuery then converting those
files to a CSV file to complex
event processing or something
like that.
Is there a way to avoid all that
process of porting data
from one structure to another?
For example, if I do incremental
updates, probably
that's going to be a pain.
KIM CAMERON: Yeah so BigQuery
right now supports two schema.
So one is CSV format
and one is JSON.
So I think in the future it
might be great if there were
more schemas.
For now it would have to
be one of those two.
So if you're starting a project
from scratch you could
think about, well is there a
way I can structure my data
that way naturally
so it's easier?
That is a limitation
right now.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious what the
500 motes you showed in the
use of mesh networks
how it was at that
mesh data got collected.
Was there some point that
brought it onto the internet?
KIM CAMERON: So I'm not sure
of the answer to that.
We focus mostly on the
software side.
And Digi were the masters of
setting up the mesh network.
So they would be able
to answer that
question better than me.
And they will be at the cloud
sandbox later on to help
answer that question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KIM CAMERON: Hi, I have
a simple question.
How did you decide where to
place each of every sensor?
AMY UNRUH: Yeah Alasdair could
answer that question.
He can tell you it was time
consuming and he probably lost
lots of his hair doing it.
KIM CAMERON: I think that is one
of the ongoing challenges.
How do you know how many
motes to put and
where do you put them.
And how dense do you
pack them in?
And these are things that sort
of learning lesson and
hopefully we improve
in the future.
AMY UNRUH: But in a sense we
place them knowing ahead of
time where we thought
interesting things
would be going on.
And that was certainly
a part of it.
AUDIENCE: So with these large
data sets like this, did you
give any thought to testing
whether the
results were correct?
AMY UNRUH: In this sense of
whether we have dirty data,
missing data?
AUDIENCE: Your calculations
were incorrect or you had
somehow overran some of
the data or didn't get
all that was there.
Sure there's, there's not
that much at risk.
AMY UNRUH: It's a really
interesting question.
There are several levels of
that question, of course.
And one is just a question of
how well calibrated are the
motes with each other.
And we believe that, we haven't
done much of this yet,
but a lot of the correlation
analysis that we're planning
on doing should help flesh
that out a little bit.
And then we anticipate that we
will have gaps in our data.
For example, motes are going on
and offline all the time.
Sometimes one of the sensors
on a mote doesn't report.
Sometimes our motes
get mislabeled.
And so any analysis we do will
have to deal with that.
Whether it be to be tolerant
of that, or to
try to clean it up.
AUDIENCE: But you're assuming
that once the data is in the
mote everything else is
going to be correct.
AMY UNRUH: You mean once we've
collected the data?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Right.
AMY UNRUH: No.
We anticipate doing all sorts
of analysis that requires a
data cleaning stage
of some sort.
It really is dirty
data, in a sense.
There's lots of gaps.
There's lots of things that
were a bit mislabeled.
And because we have so much
of it we ought to be able
to pick that out.
AUDIENCE: Right.
OK.
All right Thank you.
KIM CAMERON: Hello.
AUDIENCE: So one of things about
Google I/O, I've been
coming for a long time and our
Wi-Fi network here has been
pretty bad.
And this year, I think,
is about the worst.
And so how do you know that you
can deploy 500 motes in
this incredibly challenging
environment without
exacerbating the problems we
already have with Wi-Fi?
KIM CAMERON: Yes, let's
get Alasdair up here.
ALASDAIR: So I think ZigBee mesh
is actually in between
the Wi-Fi channels.
AUDIENCE: They're all
2.4 megahertz
channels, then they overlap.
ALASDAIR: No, well,
not exactly.
They're 2.4 gigahertz channels,
but the actual
ZigBee channels are between
the Wi-Fi channels.
So they're in that the bottoms
of the Gaussians.
On top of that, we actually
filtered out some of the
ZigBee channels that
were overlapping
with the Wi-Fi channels.
So we optimized it to
preferentially not interfere
with the Wi-Fi.
AUDIENCE: So are you measuring,
the Wi-Fi has been
really bad this year.
Are you measuring something--
ALASDAIR: Well actually I think
the Wi-Fi is really good
for a conference of the size.
I've seen much worse.
But we are actually looking for
packet loss and other sort
of packet collision
type stuff.
And we're going to look at
that data and analyze it
afterwards and see what's
happening, basically.
But I would lay large amounts
of money that anything to do
with Wi-Fi is not our network.
Hand on heart.
I swear.
AUDIENCE: OK.
All right.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I know that is a
totally different project, but
I'd like to know if you have
any comment about HP Sense.
They have a similar project
about collecting data.
KIM CAMERON: I'm personally not
familiar with the project.
Amy are you?
AMY UNRUH: I'm sorry
what was the name?
AUDIENCE: HP Sense.
I mean, the Hewlett Packard,
they have the--
AMY UNRUH: Yeah.
I'm only familiar with
it a very high level.
So I probably can't comment.
It is certainly has similar
high level goal.
Although one thing I would add
is because we're cloud
platform Devereaux, we
particularly wanted to build
this system on top of the
Google Cloud platform.
So that was this part of
our motivation for
doing it how we did.
AUDIENCE: Will BigQuery data
be available as part of
samples of the BigQuery, like
other sample tables?
AMY UNRUH: Yes, we're
making that the
BigQuery data set public.
It is already public.
And if you go to the--
KIM CAMERON: Yeah, so, and I
apologize for the slide not
being full screen.
But if go to the kiosk you can
have access to the website and
you can even mess around
with it there.
And there's instructions on
the home page of that they
tell you where the data set
is, what is called.
There's a screen shot.
It's very easy to find.
You can access it now.
AUDIENCE: Great, thank you.
AMY UNRUH: At a later point
we'll open source the code
that we did.
That probably is a couple
months down the road.
AUDIENCE: How did you place all
the mounts on the indoor
map kind of thing?
Like how did you position
the locations?
Are those real-time updating
if the position changes?
KIM CAMERON: Yeah, so the
question was regarding how do
we replace the motes
on the map.
And, correct me if I'm wrong,
Alistair, but I believe that
they had to do this manually.
So when they'd place a mote,
they would actually--
AMY UNRUH: Well I'm not
entirely manually.
We actually wrote a user
interface to facilitate that
for them a little bit.
So in fact, we used
the Maps API.
And they could drag
motes around.
And that helped quite a bit.
But there still was some hand
typing in of some long strings
of names and things like that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
KIM CAMERON: All right,
we have time
for one more question.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
When you are loading data up to
BigQuery, are you able to
append to the existing
data sets.
Do you have to replace them?
KIM CAMERON: I'm not sure
what we're doing in
this specific case.
You can append data.
AMY UNRUH: We are appending.
It's just one, big table.
And by BigQuery standards.
This is many, many megs.
By BigQuery standards
it is really not
breaking a sweat at all.
This could be many, many
gigabytes and it
would still be happy.
So for the entire course of this
conference it's all just
going into one big table.
KIM CAMERON: Thank
you, everyone.